Princess Charlene were recently seeing
her return to the spotlight for the
Queen's funeral as well as Fashion Week
how is she these days well I think the
fact that we have seen
house is really encouraging um you know
we know that there it's it's not all
being plain sailing behind the scenes
and there have been issues
um but you know I think the hope is this
is a return to public life and you know
and she's looking really really well
yeah I see the future of our monarchy
mirroring more and more those of the
royal families in Europe and like Spain
and some of the more exactly modernized
absolutely and more streamlined true you
know you think back to to the queen and
her Reign and and that sort of snapshot
of the royal family with the extended
family all up there for the trooping the
color for the Jubilee celebrations you
know Charles comes into kingship in a
very very different age in an age where
the monarchy needs to prove why they're
there why the taxpayer funds them he
wants to slim back on those costs and
that means a scaled back royal family
and I think he and William are very
aligned that that is that has to be the
future in order for it to survive so as
a scaled back monarchy a way in which
the monarchy is modernizing and evolving
in the time absolutely yeah absolutely
so because this is again they are on
taxpayer dollars they they are and you
know most people would say I think that
you know for less than two pounds or
four dollars actually the royal family
is good value for money in terms of what
it brings in for Revenue but you know
the Palaces are coming under scrutiny
Prince Charles wants to make high growth
his gloucestershire home far more
accessible to the public at the moment
the gardens are open right but this is a
house that he wants to one day leave to
the nation we know he's going to
potentially open up Balmoral more as a
museum to the public so that they can
learn more about the royal family
Buckingham Palace is going to be more
extensively open and these are all very
deliberate and carefully calculated
plans to make the monarchy more
accessible and I think to sort of dampen
that argument that they are a waste of
taxpayers money
foreign